سيقوم الرئيس بايدن
رسمياً برحلة مثيرة للجدل إلى المملكة
العربية السعودية. ما كان سرًا مكشوفًا بالفعل ،
يتم تأكيده الآن من قبل البيت الأبيض ،
وستشمل رحلة الشرق الأوسط الشهر
المقبل زيارات إلى إسرائيل
والضفة الغربية ، والجدل يحيط
بما قاله بايدن.  كمرشح تعهد
بمعاقبة المملكة وجعل
ولي العهد السعودي منبوذًا
لاغتيال الصحفي جمال
خاشقجي الذي يُنظر إليه على أنه آخر علاماتنا الحية في
البيت الأبيض مع هذا
الإعلان الرسمي أرليت ما يقولونه
جيدًا جون هذه التعليقات من
الرئيس بايدن  يبدو أنه في
مرآة الرؤية الخلفية لأنه يستعد
الآن للسفر إلى المملكة العربية السعودية الشهر المقبل ، وقال
البيت الأبيض إن هذا سيكون جزءًا من
رحلة أوسع إلى الشرق الأوسط
تمتد من 13 يوليو إلى
16 يوليو بدءًا من تلك المحطات في إسرائيل
و  الضفة الغربية الفلسطينية
سيسافر الرئيس بعد ذلك إلى المملكة
العربية السعودية حيث سيحضر قمة
مجلس التعاون الخليجي.
ومن المتوقع أن يتعامل بطريقة ما مع
ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان
الذي أظهر تقريرًا استخباراتيًا منذ أكثر من عام بقليل
أنه
أمر بهذه العملية التي قتلت
كاتب العمود في واشنطن بوست جمال
خاشقجي الآن حتى الآن كان بايدن ببساطة منخرطًا
مع  قال والد ولي العهد ،
الملك سلمان ، في بيان اليوم ،
السكرتير الصحفي للبيت الأبيض ، كارين
جان بيير ، إن الرئيس
يقدّر قيادة الملك سليمان
وابتكاره ، إنه يتطلع إلى هذه
الزيارة المهمة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
التي كانت شريكًا استراتيجيًا
للولايات المتحدة منذ ما يقرب من  ثمانية عقود ،
لكن هذا يمثل حقًا انعكاسًا ملحوظًا
في نهج الرئيس بايدن
تجاه المسؤولين السعوديين يقولون
إن الرئيس وافق على هذه الرحلة
بعد أن كان لديه بعض التردد في البداية
بعد تلك الوعود التي قطعها
كمرشح لجعل المملكة العربية السعودية تدفع ثمن
جريمة القتل أو  دورنا في
قتل جمال خاشقجي الآن ولكن هذا
يأتي أيضًا كما فعلنا  رأينا هذا
المشهد العالمي المتغير حقًا مع
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا وكذلك
أسعار الطاقة المرتفعة الآن
، قال الرئيس أه خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع إنه
لن يذهب لأسباب تتعلق بالطاقة ولكن
لأسباب تتعلق بالأمن القومي ، لكن المسؤولين
قرروا أيضًا أنهم يشعرون أن هذا هو
الصواب  حان الوقت لمتابعة علاقات أكثر دفئًا
مع المملكة العربية السعودية بالطبع
تأتي هذه الرحلة مع بعض الانتقادات هناك
من الديمقراطيين وغيرهم ممن
انتقدوا الاجتماع المحتمل بين
بايدن وولي العهد مع
خطيب خاشقجي قائلين إن
الاجتماع المحتمل أمر
مزعج للغاية.